all right Harry one okay I guess we're
live so as Aarthi was saying please
enter your son at ID we can bring this
up again at the end of class today we're
just taking another like what 20 seconds
and then we'll we'll go onto the main
discussion all right so um what I want
to discuss with you today is maybe what
I'm gonna call full cycle deep learning
applications and so I think this Sunday
you'll be submitting your proposals for
the class projects you do this quarter
and in most of the in a lot of what you
learn about the machine learning
projects you learn how to build machine
learning models what I want to do today
is share view the bigger context of how
a machine learning model you know have a
neural network my train fits in the
context of a bigger project so what are
all the steps right just as if you're
writing a software product you know you
take other classes and don't you know
that that teach you how to build a
website for example what is that
but Sybilla product requires more than
just building a website right so what
are the what are the other things you
need to do to actually do a successful
software project in this case to do a
successful machine learning application
and so let's see so - oh yeah oh
test test is the only alarm test could
you turn up the audio
No how's this nope can't hear me at all
my oh I think I'm broadcasting I hear
myself great okay you can hear me now
great thank you all right thank you all
right so one over this is share view a
full cycle machine learning not just how
to you learn a lot about how to build
deep learning models but how does that
fit in a bigger project right just as if
you're taking the claws on building a
website you know then great you know how
the code of a website that's really
valuable but what are all the things you
need to do to make a successful website
to build a build a project that involves
launching a website up mobile back or
whatever so as you plan for your class
project proposals do to Sunday if you're
doing an application project that fits
in the context of a bigger application
also take some of these steps in mind
right so you know these are what I think
of as a steps of an ml project oh really
maybe maybe not class project but maybe
you're serious machine learning
application right and I think oh no I've
built a lot of machine learning products
over several years so some of these are
also things that I wish I had known like
you know many years ago um one this was
kind of maybe kind of obvious but you
know select a problem and let's say for
the sake of simplicity that if you use
supervised learning right it turns out
for the CSU 30 class projects I think
more than 50% of the projects tend to
use supervisor and then there are also
other projects that use end up using
gans which talked about later this
quarter or all the things but I think
you know let's say you supervised
learning to build a machine application
and oh and I think for today I'm gonna
use as a running example building a
building a voice-activated device right
so you know I don't know actually how
many of you have like a smart speaker in
your home like a voice-activated device
in your home you know there were in the
u.s. well not that many of you it just
okay cool yeah so I think you know the
the Amazon echoes google homes the apple
series or the the in China might one of
my form of tea is built by two 200s but
let's say for the sake of argument that
you want to build a voice-activated
device and I'm going to use as a running
example and so in order to build a
voice-activated advice and again I'm not
gonna use any of the commercial brands
like Alexa okay Google or hey Suri or I
guess in China was a hello sale dude
won't sell do anyhow which means kind of
roughly how long I don't do um but let's
use a more neutral word which is less
you wanted to build a device that your
response to that will activate and
you're actually gonna implement this as
a problem set later
this quarter but so you want to build a
yeah okay no volume publish let's see
how they okay is this better
no yes yeah this is better okay cool
thank you no but ironic don't have
speech recognition and the volume is
higher okay um so let's say you want a
WoW is it let me know if I can suffocate
it thank you um so let's you want to
build a voice-activated device so the
key components the key machine learning
deep learning component is going to be a
learning algorithm that takes us input
and audio clip and outputs to the detect
what's sometimes called the trigger word
yeah did I go soft again okay this'll be
great alright and and O+ why you know
zero one did you to check their trigger
word such as a lexer or okay google or
history or a hollow little do or or
activate on whatever wake where they'll
trigger word right um and so
step one is select a problem and then in
order to train a learning algorithm you
need to get labeled data if you apply
supervised learning and then you design
a model use backdrop or some of the
other albums you learn about momentum
atom various optimization algorithms
gradient descent to train the model and
then maybe you test it on your test set
and then you deploy it meaning you start
selling these smart speakers and you
know putting them into hopefully until
you uses homes and then you have to
maintain the system I'll talk about this
later as well and and this is not
chronological but one thing that's often
done but I want to talk about it at the
end instead it's not really step 8 is
IQA which is a quality assurance which
is an ongoing process right and so one
let's see
so as you so if you want to build a
product if you want to sell a machine
there any product these are maybe some
of the key steps you need to work on
some observations when you train them
although training them all is often a
very iterative process so every time you
train the machine there in your model
you find that you know I can almost
guarantee whatever you do it will not
work at least not the first time right
and so you find that even though I've
written is a sequence of steps when you
train them although you're on the go
note that neural network architecture
didn't work I need to increase the
number of hidden units or change the
regularization or switch there are n N
or switch to a totally different
architecture and sometimes you train
them all and go nope that didn't work I
need to get more data right and so this
is often a very iterative process where
you're cycling through
oh there's several different steps here
and then I think one distinction that
you have not yet learned about in the
Coursera in the d-plan Dalia kosair
videos is how to split up the data into
train dev and test so I'm going to
simplify those details for now but just
as a foreshadowing you guys know what oh
you learn later in the in the deep end
ie i conserve videos is how to take a
dataset you have training to use my
entire training set into a set that you
actually test cross validate using
during development called a deficit or
development set or hold our
cross-validation set that's what's a
separate test set so you learn about
this later but I'm just simplifying a
little bit for today okay so um so I
think the first thing I want to do is
ask you a question right so we're gonna
talk through many of these steps so and
it turns out that what a lot of machine
learning classes do and do a good job
teaching is focusing on maybe these
three steps or maybe these four steps
right and what I want to do today is
spend more time so this is the heart of
machine there I mean how do you build a
green model and what I want to do today
is spend more time talking about step
one and six and seven and then just a
little bit of time talking about that
call this because you kind of need to do
the other steps was well if you wanna
throw the deep learning product or build
a machine learning application okay um
so let's sort of a discussion question
um I'm actually curious if you are
selecting a project to work on
what other actually so I don't don't
answer this yet I'll tell you what the
question I'm going to ask is which is
alright uh what properties make for a
good candidate deep learning project but
don't answer yet right now I want to say
a few more things before before I invite
you to answer which is that all of you
for the last few days I hope I've been
thinking about what price you want to do
for this cause and what I want to do is
just discuss some properties of what a
good project to work on and what are
maybe not good practice and where
okay and and think of this as your
chance to give your classmates advice
right one of the things your cosplay
should think about the challenge decides
is a good price to work on okay um and
so what I want to do for today is use
this voice-activated thing as as long as
it most an example and you know there's
actually one project I was working on
actually a father where actually there's
one project I thought of working on but
decided not to work on and that there's
a voice-activated device so it turns out
that um these voice-activated devices
and echo Google homes and so on they are
taking off quite rapidly in the US and
around the world um it turns out that
one of the you know significant pain
points of these devices is the need to
configure it right to set it up for
Wi-Fi so I've done a lot of work on
speech recognition you know a hotel de
la working on speech system
I let the by to speech system so I've
been published papers on speech
recognition and I have a I have one of
these devices in my home right actually
I have an Amazon echo in my innovative
but even to this day I have configured
exactly one light bulb to be hooked up
to be controlled by my echo because the
the set up process not blaming any
country is just difficult to hook up you
know a Wi-Fi enabled light bomb and then
to set it up so that your small speaker
or whatever as in say you know smart
device turn off the lamp so I have one
light bulb in my living room right that
I can turn on and off and that's it
right even as a speech researcher so
um we must have valleys um so one one
one application that I think that
actually sir sequencing working on is to
build a embedded device that you can
sell to lamp makers so that I don't know
where you buy an ounce from and you know
have a few Lancer Mike here if you lands
or wherever but you can buy a desk lamp
so that when you buy the desk lamp
there's already a built-in microphone so
that without needing to connect this
thing to Wi-Fi you know as I hey here's
a twenty dollar desk lamp put them on
your desk and you can go home and say
desk lamp turn on or just lamp turn off
then I think that will help a lot more
users get voice activated devices into
their home and it's actually not clear
to me if you want to turn on a desk lamp
is actually not clear to me that you
want to turn to small speaker and say
hey smart speaker please turn on that
lamp over there it may be a fuse one
actor they just talk directly to a desk
lamp and tow it to turn on the turn and
so so far well is where if someone
friends and I we evaluated this we
actually thought that this could be a
reasonable business to build embedded
devices to sell to lamp makers or other
device makers so that they can sell
their own voice-activated devices
without needing just complicated Wi-Fi
setup process and so to do this you
would need to build a learning algorithm
and have it Raman invent a device that
just inputs an audio clip and outputs
you know whenever it detects the wave
word and instead of a wake where being
activated the week where it would be a
lamp turned on or lamp turn off you need
to wake where so trigger words want to
turn it on when to turn it off right oh
and and and I think just the other thing
that I think would make this work is to
to give these devices names so if you
have five lamps or two lambs you you
need an way to index into these
different desk lamps so let's say you
decide for your project you know to have
a little switch here so this lamp could
be called John or Mary or Bob or Alice
like a four-way switch so that depending
on where you set this four-way switch
you can say you know John
turn oh right always if you decide to
call this lamb John I girls would give
us some of the names so you don't have
every lamp by the same name okay um so
what I'm gonna do is use as a motivating
example this as a possible project oh
and I'm not working on this if any of
you want to be able to start up doing
this go for it this is not know I felt
my team's night way better ideas so we
want to do other things in this by I
should don't see anything wrong with
this I think there's actually could be a
reasonable thing to pursue yourself and
I'm not doing it so yeah very welcome to
if you want okay so now the question
that one opposed to you is when you're
brainstorming project ideas you know
like this idea some other idea um what
are the things you would want to watch
out for well what are the properties
that you have want to be true in order
for you to few good proposing this as a
as a CSU 30 project right so why should
take a minute and write this down I
think uh yeah what if you're asking your
friend if a friend is asking you what
are the things I should look at to see
if something is a big project
what would you why you recommend to them
so feel free just write down a few key
words and then we'll see what people say
and then and then I'll tell you what I
tend to look out for when I'm selecting
projects and I have a list of five
points my stick like I don't know like
two minutes - oh sorry this is not
activated you're not able to answer is
up enter SS okay
just checking on yeah BAM connect to the
internet RT any ideas oh I see okay
all right let me try that it's what's
working now okay thank you yes thank you
so you take like two minutes to enter
and I think I think I can figure this
and let you enter multiple answers
mistake 2 News
all right another one minute 30 seconds
okay three two one
well maybe in hindsight that wasn't the
best visualization can people see this
well than one trying to see if all right
so detail in novels he lost his data
some of these re small human doable
number of examples during two months no
office you industrial fields clear
objective practical useful oh ok finish
in time he'll stroll life problem useful
hasn't been done computationally
tractable yeah
generalization see cool great oh let me
make some comments on fees I think I
this is this is pretty good um I had a
list of five bullet points that maybe I
just share view my list of five which is
I mean just some things I encourage you
to pay attention to well you know just
this may or may not be the best criteria
but interests I think interest just it
doesn't hopefully you'd work on
something that you actually interested
in um and then I think right data
availability which many of you cited is
a good criteria or one of the ways that
Stanford class projects sometimes do not
go well is if students spend a month to
try to collect data and after month I've
not yet found it in your car again and
then you know and then it's and there's
a lot of waste of time um one thing that
I would encourage you to consider as
well is domain knowledge um and I think
that if you are a biologist and have
unique knowledge into some aspect of
biology to which you want to apply
machine learning that will actually let
you do is very interesting project right
that is actually difficult for others to
do um and I think more generally as
advice for navigating your careers right
so yeah this is a gene because AI
machine learning deep learning there's
so much there's so many people wanting
to jump into machine learning and deep
learning actually giving example so I
sometimes talk to doctors near radiology
students including
Stanford and other universities
recognizes students that want to learn
about machine learning right because
they hear about you know deep learning
maybe someday affecting radiolysis jobs
and so they want to be part of deep
learning and so my career advice to them
is usually to not forget everything they
learned as a doctor and try to you know
do machine learning 101 from scratch and
just forget everything they learn as a
doctor and just become a CS major I
think that that path can work but I
think where radiologists could do the
most unique work that that allows them
to make the most unique contribution is
that they use their domain knowledge of
healthcare radiology and do something in
machine learning applied to radiology
right and so all right how many
Millennials are there in this class what
does that mean me me anything all right
this is really wrong yeah I I think it's
because a word cloud so everybody counts
where frequency right the money thing I
don't know have very mixed feelings
about that
all right um but I think actually fir I
actually know that some of you are
taking you know deep learning because
you work on a different discipline and
you want to do something and this hot
new exciting thing of machine learning
and I think whatever discipline you're
in if you had told me knowledge about
some other area you know Education civil
engineering biology and law taking deep
learning allows you to do very unique
work apply machine learning to your
domain right let's see um I think that I
think well I call the utility but
several of you mentioned as well
something that has a positive impact
that she helps other people and I don't
know money could be an aspect of utility
but maybe not the most inspiring one and
then I think um I think one of the
biggest challenges we face in the
industry today is still frankly is
actually good judgment on feasibility um
so today I still see too many leaders
sometimes CEOs of large companies that
stand onstage and announce to the whole
world you know we're gonna do this
machine learning project to do this by
this deadline and then 20 minutes later
I talked to their engineers and the NSA
no there's no way not happening what the
CEO just final stage how engine
motivation is not doing it and knows
it's impossible so I think one of the
biggest challenges is actually
feasibility um in fact I actually know
that a chapter of RT about the TA office
hours and I know that there been a lot
of you know long if you have been
thinking about applying end-to-end deep
learning right you know can you input
any X and output any Y and do that
accurately and sometimes it's possible
and sometimes it's not and it still
takes relatively deep judgement about
what neural networks can and cannot do
with a certain amount of data that you
may or may not be able to acquire in
order to do some of these things right
so so I think throughout this quarter
you gain much deeper judgment as well on
what is feasible and I guess no Swedish
thing I once no III knew a CEO of a very
of a large company that once told his
team he actually gave his team these
instructions he said I watched assume
that a I can do anything and and and I
think that had an interesting effect I
guess yeah cool all right so I think
step one um was select a project I hope
there's this thing project I keep some
of those things in mind um step two is
get data and so uh what I want you to do
I'm going to pose a second question and
then have some of you discuss this let's
say that you're actually working on this
you know smart voice-activated embedded
device thing right so let's say that you
and your friends wonderful startup so
train the deep learning algorithm to
detect you know phrases like John turn
on Mary turn off or Bob turn off or
whatever to sell to device makers so
that they can have low voice embedded
voice detection tripped it doesn't
require a complicated Wi-Fi setup
process right so let's see one that
let's say that you want to do this so
you need to collect some data in order
to start training a learning algorithm
okay so the second question I posed to
you is to a question in two parts but
but have you answer it all at the same
time which is um in how many how many
days let's say you actually proposed
this for your C su-30 project this
Sunday and then you start work on it you
know like on Monday or even it's not
work on it today before the proposal but
how many days would you spend collecting
data and how would you collect the data
okay and I think um actually how many of
you have participated in engineering
scrum if you know what that means
oh okay a few you they'll see the
industry okay alright so engineering
estimation when you estimate how long a
project takes one of the common
practices is use a Fibonacci sequence to
estimate how long a project will take
right and so Fibonacci sequence 1 1 2
3 5 8 13 and so on and there's roughly
powers of 2 but doesn't grow as fast as
powers 2 and Fibonacci numbers are cool
right but so so so what I want you to do
a universal special have a configuration
right when I with speech bubbles okay
yeah that's good
all right so what I'd like you to do is
in the text answer I really write two
things one is write a number how many
days do you think you spend on
collecting data you and your teammates
if you're actually doing this project
and then how how would you go about
collecting the data okay so much take
like another two minutes to write in an
answer oh I'm sorry
they're still not activated
sir all that I'm trying to hit oh you
just think that it's not helpful
all right
damn it's definitely not helpful all
right let's do this
write down your answer on a piece of
paper first and take two in this design
so the two questions are how many days
pick a number from a Fibonacci sequence
and are you oh okay yeah let's swap out
my computer varieties Oh actually yeah
oh
if hotties computers working I should go
ahead oh yeah I can just present yeah
yeah let's plug in your laptop so you
just use your laptop yeah doesn't say
when there was a network problem or web
browser problem I started using a
Firefox recently in addition to Chrome
and Safari and Dallas Firefox I tried
with other web browsers later I cook
bacon thank you
thanks Artie all right can maybe we have
made people that take another minute
from now just extend the time bit turned
alright another 10 seconds let's see my
sugar pills answers okay alright well
365 so there's a there's a there's a lot
of variance in the answers right I don't
know
download from online depends on what
data you want it turns out well so if
you're trying to find data or phrases
like John turn on then that data doesn't
exist online it turns out we're trying
to find audio clips of the web activate
there are some websites with single
words pronounced but those but not a lot
of audio clips actually so they trade
the world of the wake word is the word
activate there are some websites we can
download like maybe 10 audio clips of a
few people are saying activate but it's
quite hard to find hundreds of examples
of different people saying they were
activate
five days it falls in the sky all right
so let me suggest let me suggest that
you guys discuss with each other in
small groups what you think would be the
best strategy how many days we find
collecting the data and how would you
start going and try to convince people
next to you on that and and before I ask
you to start discussing I want to leave
you one thought which is how long do you
think I'll take you to train your first
model right and so if I take you a day
to train your first model or two days do
you want to spend X time collecting the
eternal and then spend let's say you
know I don't know just out of a deep
learning thing train them although it
might take a couple of days very
especially if you download open source
packages so so if the amount of time
needed to collect data is X followed by
two days to train your first model what
do you think X should be the amount of
time once you guys spend like two
minutes to discuss with each other and
see if you can compare their answers are
there's very large variance right once
you guys discuss if you actually if the
people sitting next to you are your
project partners why should discuss with
them how many days you think you should
spend collecting danger and how you
collect your data okay let's take two
minutes to discuss them
[Applause]
all right
all right guys so Wow all right guy hey
guys so all right lot of exciting
discussion so actually how many of you
how many of the groups wound up on the
on the low end how many of you you know
convince each other that maybe it should
be like three days or less oh just a few
of you how come so someone someone say
why why said wife oh yeah got them open
the data to test how the other works
before you were going to make a massive
you said and then anyone has had a high
end like a 13 days or more very few how
come anyone actually anyone anyone with
insights you want a share of the whole
classes you
what were you are discussing so excited
knowledge that I actually can take a
long time especially for this colony
like based on the one I gave you this
doesn't be a statue if they can make
pretty you say movieclip something like
subtitles to make generate sound like
audience it means as far as we were just
wanted to get our system live and that
would take like a time to like mine yeah
yeah yeah right yeah and then company
systems to look at subtitle videos right
like YouTube videos with captions or
something and if there's appropriately
Creative Commons data there that you
could use
yeah so let me let me tell you my bias I
just tell you what I would do if I was
working on this project
well one caveat if I haven't done so
much work and speech recognition
previously fragments was my first
project um I would probably spend one to
two days collecting today's Hera kind of
on the short end right and I think that
Dallman you know one of the and and and
one of the reasons is that machine
learning kind of that circle I grew up
there is actually a very iterative
process where um until you try it you
you almost never know what's actually
going to be hard about the problem right
and so so if I was seeing this project I
just so you wanna see what I would do
okay now that you thought about this
project a bunch right including you know
trying to validate market acceptance and
so on but um which is that I would get a
cheap microphone user or use the
built-in laptop microphone or buy a
microphone off you know buy a microphone
off Amazon or something and go around
say go around Stanford campus or go to
your friends and have them just say hey
do you mind saying into this microphone
the word activate or don't turn on or
whatever and collect a bunch of data
that way and then and with one or two
days you should be able to collect at
least hundreds of examples and that
might be enough of a data set to start
training a rudimentary learning
algorithm to get going
because if you have not yet worked on
this problem before it turns out to be
very difficult to know what's going to
be hard about the problem so it's what's
going to be hard
highly accented speakers right oh it
smells gonna be hard
background noise what's gonna be hard
you know confusing turn on with turn off
you hear John turn and then but when you
build a new machine learning system it's
very difficult to know what's hard it
was easy about the problem
what's going to be difficult that Fafi
which is the technical term for if the
microphone is very far away
all right so turns out that you know if
we turn on the microphone on my laptop
now for example the laptop which is like
three meters away from me will be
hearing voice directly from my null as
well as voice bouncing off the wall so
there's a lot of reverberation in this
room and so that makes speech
recognition harder humor here are so
good at processing out reverberant
sounds reverberations that you almost
don't notice it but it makes it actually
but but learning every room will have
sometimes has problems with
reverberations ray or echoes bouncing
off the hard walls in this room and so
depending on what you're learning album
has trouble with you will then want to
go back to collect very different types
of data or explore very different types
of algorithms well that's the problem
that sometimes it's because just the
volume is just too soft in which case
you know maybe you need to do something
else and normalize all the volumes or
buy more since it might for something so
it turns out that when building most
machine learning applications unless
you've experienced working on it so I've
actually worked on this problem before
so have a sense it was hard it was easy
but they work on the new project for the
first time it's very difficult to know
what's on it was easy and so my advice
to most teams is rather than spending
say 20 days to collect data and then two
days to collect model to train a model
and it's often by training a model and
then seeing what are the examples it
gets wrong whether the averin fail that
that lets you feedback to either collect
more data or redesign the model
right or try something else and if you
can string the data collection peering
down to be more comparable to how long
you end up taking to train your model
then you can start iterating much more
rapidly on actually improving your model
right oh and um so maybe one roof that I
should tend to recommend for most cost
projects is I don't know if it may be if
you need to spend a week up to a week to
collect data you know maybe that's okay
but you can get going even more quickly
I would even maybe more strongly
recommend that and there been so few
examples in my life where the first time
I trained the learning algorithm it
works right it like pretty much never
happens yeah it happened once about a
year ago and I was so surprised I still
remember that one time and so what so so
machine learning development is often a
very iterative process and by quickly
find a set and and often datasets are
collected through sweat and hard work
right and so I would literally you know
and actually what my version along well
speech indicate going quickly I would
probably just have myself well my team
members run around and find people and
ask them to speak into microphone and
record all your clips that way and then
only when you validate that you need a
bigger data set which you go to more
complicated things I said of an Amazon
Mechanical Turk thing right to
crowdsource which I've also done
actually I've also had very largely a
self collected of Amazon Mechanical Turk
but only in a later stage the project
and you understand what you really need
um so as you as you start work on your
class projects maybe maybe keep that
keep that in mind now
so one other tip that machine learning
researchers on average we tend to be
terrible at this but I'll give this
advice anyway is when you're going
through this process yes someday there
are design a model a literature search
would be very helpful you know so see
what other see what algorithms others
are using for this problem it turns out
the literature actually quite immature
there isn't a convergence of like a well
standard set of standard algorithms for
trigger word detection in literature
right now much people are still making
up algorithms so if you if you do the
survey you find that to be case but you
need trained initial model and in most
machine learning applications you go
through this process multiple time so
one tip that I would recommend you do is
uh keep clear notes on the experiments
you've run because so often be as we
train them although you see oh this
model works great on American accent two
speakers but not on British accent two
speakers right I was born in the UK so
I'm just use Pradesh accents run example
if you're a different part of the world
you think of different global axes it
sends down from the UK I'm just a pick
on British accents I guess keep clear
notes on the experiments run because
what happens in every machine learning
project is after a while you have
trained 30 models and then you and your
team is occurring oh yeah we tried that
idea two weeks ago didn't work and if
you have clear notes from when you
actually did that work two years ago
then you can refer back rather than have
to rerun an experiment
oh the other thing that some groups do
is have a spreadsheet that keeps track
of what's the learning rate you use
what's the number of hidden units what's
this was this was this or cheaper than a
in a text document so that which will
make it easier to refer to it to know
some ways you try earlier this is one
piece of comedy giving advice and
there's one of those things that every
machine learning person knows we should
do this but on average we're very bad at
doing
but but that you could I don't know but
at the times I manage to keep good knows
is that she save them all the time right
to try to remember what exactly you
tried two weeks ago okay so um Baba this
class will be on this process how to get
data develop the chain dev test the
design and model we train the model
eventually test them all then innovate
so a lot of us causes on this so when
they jump ahead to when you have a good
enough model and you want to deploy it
okay so step six
my guess is deployment now um this is uh
one of the reasons I want to step
through this example going through a
concrete example is I find it when
you're learning about machine learning
for the first time it's often seeing you
know what my team's tend to call wall
stories kind of stories of projects that
others have built before that often
provides the best learning experience so
I think like I have built speech
recognition systems it took me like a
year or two years ago me to do it so I'm
trying to so rather than you know having
you spend two years here alight building
speech systems if can summarize a war
story right to tell you what the process
is like I'm hoping that these concrete
examples of what building these systems
are like in you know large corporations
that that can help you accelerate your
learnings without needing to get two
years of on-the-job experience you can
just hear the salient points okay now if
you're deploying a system like this one
of the things intersection true there's
actually real phenomenon for deploying
speech systems is uh yet the audio clip
you have a new network and then you know
this will output zero one and the neural
networks that work well will tend to be
relatively large relatively large mall
the Marshall or his engine is relatively
high complexity and if you have so the
smart speakers in your home you
recognize that a lot of them are age
devices as opposed to purely crawl
computation right so we all know what
the cloud is and what an edge devices an
edge device is a small speaker that's in
your home or the cell phone in your
so edge devices are you know the things
that are close to the data is supposed
to cloud which is a giant service we
have in our data centers right so um
because of network latency and and and
and because of privacy a lot of these
computations are done on edge devices
like the small speaker in your home or
like I guess hey Suri or okay Google can
wake up your cell phone right and so
edge devices have much lower
computational budgets and much lower
power budgets limited battery life much
less powerful processors than we have in
our cloud data centers and so it turns
out that salt salt serving up a very
large neural network is quite difficult
right it's very difficult for you know a
low-power inexpensive microprocessor
sitting in the spots between your living
room to run a very large neural network
with a lot of hidden units with all the
parameters and so what is often done is
to actually do this which is to input an
audio clip and then have a much simpler
algorithm figure out if you know anyone
is even talking right because so the
smart speaker you know in my living room
here silence most of the day right
because usually just no one at home
writes no no no voice and then only if
it hears you know someone talking then
feeding to the big neural network that
you've trained and ramped up use a
larger power budget in order to classify
0 1 ok this component goes by many
different names in in reasonably
standard terminology but not totally
standard terminology in the literature
I'm gonna call this VAD for a voice
activity detection it turns out that
voice activity detection is the standard
component is in many different speech
recognition system
if you are using a cell phone for
example VAD is a component that tries to
figure there is even talking because if
it thinks no one is talking then there's
no need to encode the audio and try to
transmit the audio right yeah LT could
you know yeah um and so so the next
question I want to ask you and then I I
thought this is timely because well is a
couple options right option one is to
build an on machine learning based EAD
system voice activity detection system
which is just you know see if the volume
of the audio your spawn speakers
recording is greater than epsilon so the
silence just together and option two is
train a small neural network to
recognize on on on human speech right
and so my next question to you is if you
work on this project which you pick
option one or would you pick option to
write as you as you as you work to what
oh sorry
and I think on a small neural network so
to a small neural network or in some
cases I've seen people use a small
support vector machine as well for those
you know what that is a small model can
be run with a low computational budget
it's a much simpler problem to Detective
someone is talking than to recognize the
word this is so you can actually do this
you know what reasonable accuracy was
small new network but if you actually
work on this project for CS 230 which
would you try for us so could we come to
the next question
yeah yeah you can let them start on
screen I guess and I mean why are you
afraid other projection cool
I'll just keep unlocking it periodically
are people able to vote no they're no
pants yeah well I see I guess you write
so much code you have a shortcut to go
through your coding environment oh
you're that all right cool oh well great
right people have seen quickly another
like 20 seconds if that's enough time to
get your answers
all right cool
that's fascinating
there's a lot of disagreement in this
house people will not say why why would
you choose option 1 why would you choose
option 2 and then IIIi have a very
strong point of view on what I would do
right but but I'm curious why why option
1 and why option to go ahead either
[Music]
option 2 you can probably kind of
already like this simplify the problem
when a consultant know exists not if it
knows I mean activates the machine but
if it's out parking option to be much
better yes option 2
300 when someone's whistling oh yeah
right if you're in the noisy place like
you know I have a friend who saw the
statue this next a train station and so
right so option one we picked up a lot
the train which ever it has to be
running constantly so you want something
in Spanish so it seems like option one
is better because yeah whether it has to
become running constantly you still want
to be like no power no country so let me
show you for the pros and cons um so um
I think you know there are pros and cons
option when the option to versus while
you're sewing so so many votes for both
options I perceive would choose option 1
but but let me just let's just discuss
the pros and cons right I think that um
option 1 um first is just a few lines of
code this is yes maybe option 2 isn't
that complicated but option 1 is even
simpler and I think that um actually
maybe I would say if I hadn't worked on
this problem before I which is option 1
but since I have experience as feature a
commission eventually I know you need
option 2 but that's because I because
I've worked on this problem before but
if your first time work on the speech
application problem I would encourage
you on average to try to really simple
quick and dirty solutions and go ahead
and so let's see how long would it take
you to implement this right I would say
like 10 minutes five minutes I don't
know right Harlan would think of them
with that oh four hours one day I I
don't really know actually right now let
me just write one day and I'm not quite
sure all right
but if um option one commence in 10
minutes then I would encourage you to do
that and go ahead and put the
smart speaker in your home or in your
potential users homes and only when you
find out that the dog barking is a
problem or the train on the railway
sings you know whatever it's a problem
then go back and invest more in fixing
it right and in fact um it's true that
maybe it's annoying that the dog barking
keeps on waking up the system
but maybe that's okay because if the
large new network then screens out all
the dog barking then the overall
performance system is actually just fine
and and and then you now have a much
simpler system rights but but but it
turns out that um the reason you might
need to go to option to eventually is
because there are some homes in noisy
environments
you know this constant background noise
and so that will keep the large new
network running longer too frequently so
so if you have a large engineering
budget you know so it's not the small
speaker teams are hundreds of engineers
working on it they have hundreds of
engines work on that totally options who
will perform better but if you're
strapped a start-up team is scrappy
startup team with three of you work on a
cross project you know the evidence that
you need that love of complexity is not
that high and I would really do that
first and and use that to gather
evidence that you really should make the
investment to build more complex system
before actually making the investments
of days or and eventually I think this
is one day to put your first prototype
right and then eventually will be will
be more complicated um it turns out that
the other reason the other huge
advantage of the simple method is the
following oh and this is one of the
frankly this is one of the this is
actually one of the big problems and big
weaknesses of machine learning
algorithms and deep learning of rooms
which is what happens is uh when you
build a system and you should ship a
product the data will change right and
so I'm gonna sin Phi the example of it
but you know I know Stanford is very
cosmopolitan
this powell's is very hot so on see the
collect data in this region you get
access from people all over the world
right because because that's Stanford
all that's
although but but just to simplify these
app a little bit let's say that you
train on u.s. accents right but you know
for some reason when you ship a product
maybe it sells really well in the UK and
you start getting data with UK or with
British accents so one of the biggest
problems you face in practical
deployment of machine learning systems
is that the data you train on is not
going to be the data you need to perform
well on and and I'm going to share with
you some practical ideas for how to
solve this but this is one of those
practical realities and practical
reasons is machine learning that is
actually not talked about much in
academia because it turns out that the
data says we have in academia are not
selling well for researchers to study
and publish papers on this I think we
can sell new machine learning benchmarks
in the future but there's one of those
problems that is actually kind of
underappreciated in academic literature
but that is a problem facing many many
practical deployments machine learning
algorithms and and so more generally eat
the problem is one of data changing
right and you might have new classes of
users with new accents or you might
train a lot on the maybe you get data
from even Stanford users and maybe
Stanford is not too noisy or Stanford at
certain you know types of characters
things when you ship it to another city
another country there's much more noisy
you know different background noise
right or you start manufacturing the
small speaker and to lower the cost of
the speaker they swap it out they swap
out the high-end microphone that you use
from your laptop to collect the data
from low-end microphone this very common
thing done in you know well done the
manufacturing right if you can use a
cheaper microphone wine
and often to human ears the sound sounds
just fine on a cheaper microphone but if
you change your learning algorithm using
your you know I guess yeah well I use a
map but the Mac has a pretty decent
microphone so if you train the data
using all your craft or a Mac and then
eventually is a different microphone it
may not generalize well so one of the
challenges of machine learning is that
you often develop a system on one
dataset and then when you ship a product
something about the world changes and
your system needs to perform on a very
different type of data than what you had
trained up and so and so what would
happen is after you deploy the model the
world may change and you often end up
going back to get more data redesign the
model right and I guess sorry and this
is this is a the maintenance of the
machine learning model only give some of
the examples web search right this
happens all the time at multiple search
engines which is you train a neural
network or you train a system to give
relevant web search results but then
something about the world changes your
for example there's a major public web
and some new person is elected president
of some foreign country or there's a
major scandal or just the internet
changes right or there's a actually what
happens in China is a new words getting
invented all the time in China China
says that by of were that Google and
Baidu but the Chinese language is more
fluid than the English language and so
new words get invented all the time and
so the language changes and so whatever
your train just isn't working as long as
it used to right or maybe a different
company suddenly shuts off you know
their entire website to your search
index because they don't want you
indexing their website and so the
internet changes and what have you had
done doesn't work anymore or
self-driving
it turns out if you build a self-driving
car in California and then you try to
deploy these vehicles in Texas you know
it turns out traffic lights in Texas
look very different than traffic lights
in California so um although it rained
on California Texas so a new network
trained to recognize California traffic
lights actually doesn't work very well
on Texas traffic lights right I'm trying
to remember which way round leanest I
think California Texas has a different
distribution of horizontal versus
vertical traffic lights for example
right it's actually humans don't else's
you go oh yeah red yellow green but the
learning algorithm doesn't actually
generalize that well if you go to
different locations go to a foreign
country again traffic light signage the
lane markers all change or I guess what
one example is working on earlier this
week right manufacturing right landing a
guy working on inspection of parts and
factories and so if you are doing visual
inspection in the factory and the
factory starts making a new component
you know they're making this model cell
phone but cell phones turn over quickly
and so but in a few months later they're
making a different type of cell phone or
something weird happens in a vacuum
process so the lighting changes with a
new type of defect so the world changes
and um so what I'd like to do is
actually revisit the previous question
in light of this the world changes
phenomenon right which is let's say
you've collected all data with American
accent two speakers and then you know we
ship the product in the UK and then and
then for some reason you find that
you've all these British accent speakers
right trying to use your spot speaker so
between these two algorithms the non
machine learning approaches I said the
threshold versus train a neural network
which system do you think would be more
robust for dat voice activity detection
all right take like another 40 seconds
all right yeah interesting if you want
to comment well more people voted for
non ml just want to explain why for the
VAD boys activity section if you just
measure the volume then it doesn't
really depend on on the accent like so
non ml might be more robust anyone else
all right so okay let me show you I
thought so it turns out that um if you
train a small neural network to you know
American accent is speech there's a
bigger chance that your neural network
because it's so clever right that'll
learn to recognize American speech and
have a harder time generalizing to
British accent in speech he says and so
one of the things that have seen a lot
of teams where is so one way the non-mo
thing could fail to generalize would be
a British speakers are systematically
you know allowed there or softer than
American speakers right sir
you know I don't know I don't have
Americans saris Oakley allowed their own
less loud and British but but you know
but if but if American British because
one one country just as louder voices
and softer voices then maybe the
threshold you set won't generalize well
but that seems unlikely right I don't
see that being realistically but but
they were training on your network a lot
parameters then it's more likely that
the neural network will pick up on some
idiosyncrasy of American accents to
decide the cities even speaking and thus
maybe less robust to generalizing into a
British accent speech right and another
way to think about this is if you
imagine to take it even further example
imagine that you're using VAD for a
totally different language than intent
in English right where take a different
language you know Chinese or Hindi you
all Spanish or something where the
sounds are really different
if you create a VAD system to detect you
know English
it may not at all work for detecting
Spanish or Chinese or French or or some
other language and so if you think of
British accents as somewhere on the
spectrum not the foreign language
binding means but just more different
then I think the nominal system is more
likely to be robust and so one lesson is
that too many that a lot of machine
learning teams during the hard way is uh
if you don't need to use a learning
algorithm or something if you can hand
code a simple room like if volume
greater than 0.01 do this all that those
rules are
can be more robust and the one of the
reasons we use learning algorithms is
when we can't hang called something
right I don't know how the hand comes
something to detect a cat or to take a
car in the real goal detect the person
so use learning our ones for those but
there's actually hand coded rule that
actually does pretty well you find that
it is more robust to ships in the data
and will often generalize better oh and
if any of you take a we talked about
this about this little bit in CS 239 I
think this is your ninety talks about
this as well but this particular
observation is backed up by very
rigorous learning theory and the
learning theory is basically that the
fewer parameters you have if you still
do well on your training set if you can
have model with very few parameters that
does well on your training set you
generalize better right so there's this
very rigorous machine learning theory
that basically says that and in the case
of the non machine learning approach
there's maybe one parameter which is
what's the threshold for epsilon and
that's welcome well now for your
training set then you're also fit
generalizing even when the data changes
is um much higher right um now the last
question um I want to post the
discussion today is when when discussing
deployments oh and so one of the lessons
deployment is that's just a way the
world works you know build a machine
learning system deploy it the world will
usually change and you often end up
collecting data and have it integrated
and maybe improve the model right and
they're fixing waffle for British
speakers or nothing um so we talked
about edged appointments as well called
appointments and so um ignoring issues
of user privacy and latency which is
super important but for purposes
question let's let's let's put aside
issues of user privacy and network
latency if you need to maintain the
model sorry maintenance means updating
the model right even as the world
changes
sorry I missed mr. history does a column
or H deployment make maintenance easier
if not of right why don't you watch you
just enter a one-word answer
and why right and so maintenance is
going the world changes something
changes so you need to update the
learning model to take it back take care
of this British accent so which type of
deployment makes it easier let me just
take like yeah another two minutes and
your answers
all right another 50 seconds
all right cool see what people wrote Wow
cool great all right almost everyone the
same college most people are saying
cloud alright cool
great and then just to summarize I think
there are two reasons why most people
say this is easier push updates that's
part of it I think the other part of it
is that if all the data lives at the
edge if all the data's process you know
they use this home and then if it comes
to crawl then even if you have all these
unhappy British accents and users you
may not even find out right you say the
company headquarters you have all these
users that mysteriously
you know seem to be not using your
device maybe because they're in
satisfied with it but if the data isn't
coming into your service in the cloud
then you may not even find out about it
now there's serious issues about user
privacy as well security right so so so
please if you ever bought the product
please be respectful of that and then
take take take care of that in a very
thoughtful and respectful way of users
but if first if so this is the cloud if
you have a lot of edge devices and all
the data is processed there um you won't
even know what your users are doing and
they're happy unhappy you just don't
know
but if some of the data are in the
stream to your service at the cloud and
if the user privacy would really
please use good music consent tell
people what you doing on the data but if
you take care of that you know in a
reasonable and sound way if you're able
to examine some of the data then you can
at least figure out that gee looks like
analyzing the data there are these
people this acts on this background
noise that is giving it back rather than
experience and you can also maybe have
the data so you can gather the data from
the edge to feedback to your model right
so so lets you detect that something's
gone wrong it lets you have the data to
retrain the model to solve the British
accent problems you can retrain the
model for a lot
British accent to speak and then finally
lets you push them all back home okay so
the first unless you detect what's going
on - it gives you data for training then
three unless you more easily push the
model back up push push the new model to
a production it's a deployment okay oh
and this is also why even if your
computation needs to run on the edge if
you could in a way respectful of user
privacy in this transparent about how
you use data if you can get even a small
sample of data or have a few volunteer
users send you some data back to the
cloud that will greatly increase your
ability to detect there's something gone
wrong as well maybe give you some data
to retrain the model so even if you can
only do so that push updates right this
this will just will help greatly okay um
all right so finally one last comment I
think one one one last challenge is a
lot of machine learning systems you're
not done at deployment there's a
constant ongoing maintenance process and
I think one of the processes you know AI
teams are getting better on this wall I
set up QA to make sure that we update
the model you don't break something so I
think QA and large companies Quality
Assurance process it's called testing us
and I think the way you test machine
algorithms is different in the way you
test try there's no software because the
performance of machine learning
algorithms is often measured in a
statistical way right so it doesn't work
and it doesn't work it neither works no
doesn't work instead it works you know
95 percent of the time or something and
so lot of companies are evolving the QA
processes that this type of statistical
testing to make sure that even you
change the modern you to push update its
the works you know 95 or 99 percent of
the time or something rather than so-so
so putting in place new QA test
processes as well ok all right I hope
that was helpful stepping through what
the full arc of a machine learning
project will look like well well later
this for certain course vias was no
later lectures are present we keep
talking about machine learning strategy
and how to make business
so let's break for today